I'm Brian Thomas great to have you with
us today the South Korea has accused the
north of blowing up a joint liaison
office near the border between those two
countries the office seen here when it
was opened in 2018 handles inter-korean
relations it's situated in the town of
Kaesong that's just north of the border
the explosion comes as tensions between
the two sides escalate over a
leafletting campaign Pyongyang is
furious has Seoul's failure to stop
activists from air-dropping
propaganda over the border into the
north okay let's get up-to-date on this
breaking news story from correspondent
Frank Smith joining us from South
Korea's capital Seoul good day to you
Frank what's the latest what caused this
incident well this is really an
escalation of what had been kind of an
ongoing campaign from North Korea to
protest against the leafleting that you
mentioned the flying of balloons across
the border by a couple of NGOs one led
by Park Sung Hawk who I interviewed
recently and one led by bak jang-ho his
brother who sends North Korea rice in
bottles by the ocean currents
periodically these two activists North
Korean defectors routinely do this to
get the message to North Koreans that
they would like to see them rise up
against what they see as a corrupt Kim
dynasty in North Korea of course this
has infuriated the north with kim
yo-jong leader Kim jong-un's brother
issuing this statement just on Saturday
night
she says before long a tragic scene of
the useless north-south joint liaison
office completely collapsed would be
seen so we did have some warning that
this explosion would take place so all
of this the pushing the tensions we've
seen rising over the past few days yes
that's correct
and it's not likely to die down soon
as I mentioned I spoke with the leaders
of the these two NGOs boxing hockey and
bought jung-ho both of them say they're
going to continue with their campaigns
despite the efforts of the South Korean
government to prevent them with police
trying to block their roads to their
access points to fly these leaflets and
rice and messages into North Korea so
it's possible we could see an escalation
of tension here on the Korean Peninsula
mmm some some of the latest threats that
that we've been seeing from North Korea
have been attributed to kim yo-jong
she's the sister of North Korean leader
of course Kim jong-un what do you make
of that well that's very correct it is
important to take a look at this it's
kind of the rise of Kim Jung Jung if we
remember just a month or two ago when
the rumors about Kim jong-un's grave
illness and possible death had come out
that proved to be false actually we were
talking about who might be the next
leader of North Korea and of course kim
yo-jong was front and center i
interviewed experts here in the South
Korean capital at that time and they
said if we see propaganda out of North
Korea
praising Kim Jung Jung putting her
forward as a spokesperson of North Korea
then the game for the throne would be
over and kim yo-jong would be the
presumptive heir to the leadership of
north korea and that's very possible
that we're seeing now Frank so thanks
very much for that
from Seoul today South Korea